manifestation has become a bit of a  buzzword in recent times so I asked a  neuroscientist whether the Law of  Attraction can actually change your life  there is this idea that you can create  this fantasy of the life that you want  and sit at home and wait for it to come  true and do nothing about it the science  but also just my way of going about life  is that yeah create that dream that  ideal and and and do the collage and  have it somewhere in your house that you  look at it all the time and visualize it  becoming true  also you have to go out there and do  things to make it come true you know if  you say oh I really want to get married  and have a baby well start looking after  your health and meeting suitable people  rather than going out partying all the  time if you think I really hate my job  but it pays the bills but I'd love to  you know go off and be a freelance  whatever ask yourself what you can  actually do about that